welcome to this video what is this take
me home country roads at John Denver not
quite sure anyway so we got an English
opening Colorado opening would be
hitting probly for John Denver anyway so
he goes eform jump ship before i think
is what is normally played here i have
played this a bit with white some years
ago but admittedly i forgot most of it
hmm i remember recently I saw a game my
black actually canceled long I found
that really interesting and got this
back to c5 let's just do it prevent any
pins can i play which should be six
Queen d7 and long castle so is that said
it should be too much
King edge to g5 that's kind of brutal
yes 995 a certain mo but it's a case
Wham well if you have said a you
probably should say beep and some it's
it's it's really hard to to I mean you
really have to do that if you had this
plan all along 95 forever looks looks
like a problem I don't like very much to
to check with the bishop but it's it's
what I have to do and then night 94
probably that looks bad yeah that was a
very very unsound way to play that what
I did here what is he doing she takes
looks very normal he takes us a weird
move I mean maybe it's not bad but it's
a strange so if I go if I don't go to d4
he will play D for himself I guess so
let's go here
okay interesting
now if i take that's that's neat if I
cheek yeah actually Queen Jackson is a
bit bit awkward to say the least
it's difficult not to check check I mean
g4 is also absolute rubbish and so I
make my ruckus it's on a seven wow
that's really a really really bad game
bye-bye black yeah this pawn is not very
strong the c7 porn
I you might even go F form that sets an
additional problem
and yeah great so getting better with
every move
hmm yeah I mean 97 he can take on them
you can he can take on c7
I maybe I can check here first that's a
little bit irritating at least ya know
97 not sure I've rook c7 Dennis how good
that is I mean probably it is good but
at least it's a bit it's a bit down a
bit confusing Luke c7 is probably good
because is 600 thread
no place that right away with this
problem which is probably not a bad idea
qtk has got that those chicks as well
time morning ji oh I know I know
check
ragini I had intended to t get but
anyway Jim yes a chick on c8 I cannot
even play okay to what a shame
hmm chan and it doesn't look good but it
said lost I mean hello I'm kind of still
in the game at least I don't see direct
loss now for me
okay got that one bag you cannot really
avoid the green trade however yeah just
do it okay I'm not I wasn't afraid of
rook takes pawn takes was was more more
problematic I think with the bishop
opening up all of a sudden biggest
problem now is the time check ok got
that porn Wow turn around check check I
totally fell apart them from a former
from behind position and I was stupid
should where I go here check
let's go catch the h-bond white resign
yeah I was I really played played that
very very badly was a very very fishy
opening concept I had seen something
like that that someone played equipped
long castling somehow and went for some
attack but that's really just just bad
after after exactly how we played is
good maybe queen d 8 is better him
probably it is that's just rubbish there
should be three is strong it's just very
strong hip-checked i played a very good
game there up to this point everything's
everything's good form yeah the other
capture is actually better and this is
this is some giving me more chances in
comparison I'd even have that that's a
bit tougher it's not super clear but
divided at just a terrible position 6
yeah g4 is winning check that probably
also but 24 hmm yeah and now here and he
can take check it just just a disaster
check yeah then also wins but rook g3 is
winning that's cute that's cute even
that is a threat Farooq g8 made
something like that I have not just one
that's cute Wow
check this this is nice okay but you can
do this and threaten this context h6 air
over over over over yeah yeah that was
BB 5 is good something back here now it
just it's just terrible everything else
would be chanted putting it mildly yeah
ID takes this is clearly the better
movie you have to activate that Bishop
now and I don't know what to do with
that bond check and now I'm better I'm
really better the structure is good and
denied only five is stronger than his
bishop okay that was a mistake be sure
before this may be still holding yeah
but well don't try that there's a job
that opening set up that it shows them
thanks for watching